oh hi you know we don't cover a whole
lot of pc games here at game life and
there's a very good reason for that i
don't understand computers too hard too
many buttons i don't think i should be
made to know what a driver is or how
much ram i have but anyway this week
there is a new game and it's only out on
pc for now so i kind of had to suck it
up if you're a fan of the webcomic penny
arcade you probably already know that
penny arcade adventures on the rain
slick precipice of darkness episode 3 is
out this week on pc and coming soon to
xbox live indie games if you've played
the previous two episodes you'll find
that this one is totally different
episode three is still a role-playing
game focused on battling groups of
enemies the difference this time is that
it's an homage to the 16-bit
role-playing games of the 1990s if
you're one of the people who rue the day
that final fantasy ever discovered
polygons you will love this pitch
perfect throwback to blocky sprites and
lo-fi music it's not just aping a
general style either these are
references to specific games the
character designs are right out of final
fantasy vi the map screen is clearly
from super mario world and the gameplay
itself is the most interesting homage
it's a combination of the classic game
grandia with the timeline bar showing
when you and your enemies will complete
your attacks and final fantasy v gives
us the job change system where you can
mix and match different specialties to
create unique blended characters
of course since this is penny arcade the
jobs are things like slacker hobo
krabomancer and gardener and yes you can
be both a gentleman and a scholar at the
same time episode 3 has all of the
acerbic profane humorous writing you
love about the penny arcade comic mixed
with some very funny and surprising
artwork
if you like penny arcade adventures
episode 3 be sure to also check out
developer z boy games other throwback
roleplaying games that's breath of death
7 and cthulhu saves the world
that's it for this week we'll see you
next time on game life
you